let's take a more detailed look at the
situation on the ground now and we're
joined by air marshall Edward Stringer
Edward thanks a lot for joining us again
this afternoon so what is the situation
broadly on the ground in Ukraine
yeah I think Hearthstone is the big
story
um at the moment and we've seen in the
Russians saying over the last couple of
weeks how they're pulling out their
their civilians from her song which
remember they claimed to have annexed
only on the 29th of September uh three
weeks ago but overnight the Ukrainian
general staff has pointed out that they
are tracking now the Russians beginning
to withdraw their most valuable military
equipment a sure sign that they are
planning to give up their hold on the
West Bank and that's going to be
difficult fighting withdrawal is a
difficult thing to do would you want to
be the last person out of the territory
or across that bridge difficult to do
requires committed troops very good
command and control things we haven't
seen from the Russian army and I suspect
the ukrainians are going to make life
very difficult for them and try and turn
that into a route it would mean that
Russia gives up the only major city it's
captured in uh her son and it leaves it
then failing once again on the
battlefield with indulging instead in
these terrorist tactics we've seen
recently using the so-called suicide
drones against infrastructure targets or
the civilian population all of which is
of course uh war crimes so yeah so
that's had us on the the Nipper River
that's where all the bridges are that
they're trying to to get across are
there any Bridges actually still
standing there yeah there were there
were two Bridges there's the uh the the
main road bridge into her song and then
if you go up the river there's a bridge
across the dam at Nova
novakarkovka and those are the only two
major Crossing poets and the ukrainians
have been hitting both of those in in
recent months with high miles and other
Precision okay now talk us through
um what you know or what anyone knows
about these accusations by Vladimir
zielinski that the Russians are
preparing to blow up a dam as a
hydroelectric plant
that is the um novakarkovka Dam which is
two miles long
um is a major Dam supplying
hydroelectric power the Russians are
claiming that the ukrainians are going
to attack it ukrainians I think much
more plausibly saying that's the
Russians setting things up for a false
flag operation so that's what they're
saying that they're going to blow and
that dam is going to if it did it would
flood the valley I assume well you can
see how big that uh that that
lake is really it's more than the lake
isn't it it's an inland sea and all that
water would flood into the southern area
of Hurst on not just the city but the
whole of the Herson Province and create
widespread destruction it would be a
major war crime but do you think they're
doing bit there uh I don't I think they
have mined the bridge as part of their
Terror campaign to try and shock people
so that they will negotiate with the
Russians and give them what they want
what the Russian army can't win for them
on the battlefield but the real reason I
think they won't do it is because that's
the source of the water that's piped
through to Crimea and so it'd be a big
shot in the foot for for the Russians to
take out their sole water supply to the
peninsula of Crimea itself